a killer doll returns RoboCop hits the
streets and an Interstellar Alien War
rages on several long-awaited sci-fi
sequels are finally blasting off here's
when you can expect them to hit theaters
directed by Stephen cable Jr
Transformers rise of the beasts will
bring back the popular Autobots while
introducing several new to the films
Beast Wars characters Capo will be
working from a script written by Joby
Harrell who was also responsible for the
screenplay for King Arthur legend of the
sword and wrote for Disney pluses
Obi-Wan Kenobi series Transformer 7 will
star Hamilton actor Anthony Ramos
alongside actor Dominique Fishback plus
Michelle yo Will Voice maximal air razor
Peter Dinklage will play the villainous
Scourge and Pete Davidson will play
Autobot Mirage replacing the late
Francisco Quinn the movie will take
place in the 1990s as the autobot to
maximals do battle with the Decepticons
Predacons and terracons Transformers
rise of the beasts is set to hit
theaters June 9th 2023
within days of the release of Dune a
sequel was officially Greenland where
the release date set for November 3rd
2023. Dune part 2 won't come as a shock
to anyone who read Frank Herbert's novel
or saw the first film which ended at
what seemed to be a pretty pivotal point
in the character Arc of protagonist Paul
Atreides Dune began a sprawling tale of
feuding households political maneuvering
religious Intrigue and resource mining
on the desert planet of aracas of course
not all the central players in Dune
survived until the end but those that
did are expected to reprise their roles
in the sequel also returning our
director denive and composer Hans Zimmer
as for vilnov the director clarified
that he considers Dune part 2 the same
movie as dune rather than a traditional
sequel telling The Hollywood Reporter
it's not a sequel where it's another
episode or another story with the same
characters it actually has direct
continuity to the first movie it's the
second part of the big huge movie that
I'm trying to do joining the cast for
Doom 2 are Florence Pugh who will play
Princess Ireland Carino and Christopher
Walken as Emperor shaddam IV Austin
Butler will portray the villainous fade
rotha Leia say do will join the cast as
lady Margot and Tim Blake Nelson is
portraying an unknown character
interestingly unlike the first film Dune
part 2 will receive an exclusive 45-day
theatrical window rather than the
simultaneous theatrical and streaming
release that the first film got come
with me while the nearly silent a quiet
place stays entirely focused on one
small family headed by parents played by
Emily Blunt and John Krasinski the
sequel a quiet place part 2 zooms out
that film brings the surviving
characters from the first film into
contact with a small peaceful community
that has managed to stay isolated from
The Sound seeking monstrosities prowling
the world around them now a third a
quiet place film is on the docket the
Paramount is positioning it as a
spin-off according to deadline writer
director Michael sarnoski will oversee a
quiet place day one word has it that
Blunts and Krasinski won't appear here
instead the leads will be played by
Lupita Nyong'o and Joseph Quinn yongo
posted a cast photo to Instagram in
March 2023 revealing that jaiman hansu
would return to the quiet place Universe
likely reprising his role as man on
island from a quiet place part 2.
a quiet place day one will be released
on March 8 2024.
everybody's favorite Titans Godzilla and
King Kong have begun training for their
anticipated rematch the first film hit
theaters and HBO Max in 2021 earning 468
million dollars at the box office and
impressing a fair amount of critics the
man in charge of the film Adam Wingard
will be returning to direct and this
time he's teaming up with an old friend
deadline reports that Dan Stevens will
be playing the lead character Stevens
and Wingard previously worked together
on the horror cult classic the guest if
you haven't seen that 80s inspired flick
you probably know Stevens from projects
like Downton Abbey Beauty and the Beast
and Legion he'll be joined by monster
verse veterans Rebecca Hall Brian Tyree
Henry and Kaylee hoddle along with
fellow newcomers Rachel house Paula Chen
and Alex burns the script is being
written by long time Wingard
collaborator Simon Barrett as well as
Jeremy Slater and Terry rossio but
what's the plot we have a vague idea
based on the official plot description
which states that Kong and Godzilla will
be pitted against an Undiscovered threat
so who or what is the Undiscovered
threat whatever ends up happening we're
excited for The Showdown Warner Brothers
recently announced that the movie's name
is Godzilla X Kong the new Empire and
will arrive in theaters on March 15
2024.
following three successful films in the
rebooted Planet of the Apes franchise a
fourth is on the way from director West
ball the three films seem to reach their
natural end with 2017's War for the
Planet of the Apes but now Kingdom of
the Planet of the Apes loons on the
horizon with ball saying on Twitter in
2020 that the fourth film would continue
the legacy of Caesar of course Caesar
the leader of the Apes in the first
three films died in war so where will
the fourth film Go From Here according
to the Hollywood Reporter Kingdom will
take place years after Caesar's death
with Apes running the show and humans as
the lower class while some apes are
trying to live a peaceful existence
others are trying to build Empires
enslaving their fellow primates and
hunting for game-changing human Tech the
story will follow an ape who stands up
to his bloodthirsty Brethren as well as
a human woman who will help our furry
hero while advancing her own goals as
for the cast a when Teague has been cast
as the lead eight and he'll be joined by
co-stars Bria Allen Peter Macon and
William H Macy the script will be
written by Patrick Cason Josh Friedman
and Amanda silver and Rick Joppa talking
to film speed the latter two elaborated
a bit on the themes of the upcoming
movie saying Caesar created something
and left a legacy so then the questions
are what happens with that What Becomes
of his legacy
I do not start this War Kingdom of the
Planet of the Apes is scheduled for a
May 24 2024 release
an allegory about environmentalism and
imperialism Avatar was a visually
stunning experience sets in the distant
future on the idyllic planet of Pandora
the film saw an earth-based contingent
seeking a rare substance and interacting
with the indigenous blue-skinned Navi in
the middle of all this paralyzed former
Marine Jake Sully fully embraced the
navi Culture by way of his mental link
up or rather his avatar from 2009 to
2010 Avatar became a worldwide pop
culture sensation and the highest
grossing movie ever made writer director
James Cameron announced weeks after the
first film hit theaters that he was
working on a sequel and later Cameron
promised a third Avatar by 2015 those
plans had ballooned into a five film
series of course such complicated movies
take a lot of money and time to realize
and the aquatics heavy Avatar the way of
water hit theaters 13 years after the
original but audiences packed theaters
as they ad for the first film to the
tune of 1.9 billion dollars in ticket
sales in the wake of the first sequel's
success Cameron has dropped some details
about Avatar 3 telling deadline fire has
a symbolic purpose in the film and
there's a culture that is specifically
around that concept you're going to meet
two completely new cultures in the next
film evidently this Fire Nation will be
a bit different from your normal Navi
led by una Chaplin the so-called Ash
people will actually be a villainous
Bunch with Cameron telling 20 minutes I
want to reveal the navi from another
angle because so far I have only shown
their good signs in the early films
there are very negative human examples
and very positive Navi examples in
Avatar 3 will do the reverse
why did you come to us
to learn according to collider the third
Avatar opens on December 20th 2024.
killer dolls amassed devoted cult
audiences by combining innocent
childhood playthings with evil murder
Mayhem and usually a little comedy
following in the steps of Chucky
Annabelle and the boy comes Megan a
high-tech take on the formula in this
film a toy company's roboticist creates
Megan an eerily life-like doll with
sophisticated Artificial Intelligence on
board she's able to learn and adapt to
make life better for the child she's
imprinted upon in this case the
roboticists niece naturally things go
awry and Megan becomes violently
overprotective of her young charge
according to deadline Megan earned 30
million dollars on its January 2023
opening weekend far exceeding industry
prognostication just Days Later
Universal took the early steps to bring
a sequel to the big screen according to
the Hollywood Reporter Allison Williams
and violet McGraw are returning for the
sequel as is Aquila Cooper who penned
the original trip according to the trade
it's unknown if original director Gerard
Johnstone is returning but we do know
that James 1 Jason Blum and Williams
herself will be producing expect Megan
2.0 to arrive in theaters on January 17
2025.
before John boyega was known for
fighting Intergalactic Space Battles in
Star Wars he was fighting unsettling
monstrous aliens in the urban sci-fi
Adventure Attack the Block written and
directed by Joe Cornish the 2011 film
starred boyega as Moses the leader of a
Teenage street gang in South London a
gang that decides to rid their
neighborhood of vicious
extraterrestrials after they
unexpectedly start falling from the sky
chasing that down I'm killing her the
sequel will reunite boyega and Cornish
who's once again both writing and
directing this time boyega will also be
acting as co-producer in addition to
reprising his role as Moses speaking to
deadline boyega said it's been a decade
since Attack the Block was released and
so much has changed since then I'm
excited to see this heightened story
returned to the Streets of London Moses
has remained one of my favorite
characters to play and bringing him back
is a huge honor according to deadline
the Attack the Block sequel will find
Moses nearing the age of 30 and
reflecting on a London Changed by real
life events like the Riots of 2011 and
rampant gentrification boyega went on we
go back and look at the locations where
we shot the first movie Once dodgy areas
and we find that it's all gleaming
high-end apartments in Starbucks there's
a whole world that we're about to
explore here with a whole new take on
that Universe building and revisiting
those characters
every few years another Cloverfield
movie comes along Cloverfield sequels
have historically been developed under
code names and aren't revealed to be
part of the popular franchise until
their trailers hit the big and small
screens or in the case of 2018's the
Cloverfield Paradox just before the film
hit Netflix on Super Bowl Sunday all
three Cloverfield movies are
dramatically different from one another
2008's Cloverfield is a found footage
horror movie about a stampeding monster
2016's 10 Cloverfield Lane takes place
almost entirely in a bunker and the
Cloverfield Paradox is a space Thriller
considering this history of secrecy it's
likely nobody will know what the fourth
Cloverfield movie is really about until
just before it's released which will be
sometime in the next few years
according to the Hollywood Reporter
franchise producer JJ Abrams hired
writer Joe Barton to write the
screenplay in January 2021. in September
2022 babakavarney landed the director's
job following his well-received work on
thoughtful and unsettling Fair including
under the Shadow and I came by almost
everything else about the movie in true
Cloverfield fashion remains a mystery
adapted from the book by Richard
Matheson the 2007 film I Am Legend
starred Will Smith as Robert Neville the
seemingly sole human Survivor of an
apocalyptic plague that transformed most
of the world's humans into a terrifying
cross between zombies and vampires
however Neville eventually encounters
another pair of survivors a woman and a
young boy who are both also immune to
the virus the ending of the film didn't
leave a lot of room for Smith to return
for a sequel since it's all Neville
sacrificing himself in order to save the
other two but an alternate ending found
all three heading to a survivor's camp
in possession of a cure
what are you doing
I'm listening according to the original
film's writer Akiva goldsman the sequel
announced by deadline in 2022 would
follow that other ending goldsmen told
deadline this will start a few decades
later than the first we traced back to
the original Matheson book and the
alternate ending what Matheson was
talking about was that man's time on the
planet as the dominant species had come
to an end that's a really interesting
thing we're going to get to explore
Michael B Jordan is set to headline I am
Legend 2 along with Smith however not
long after I am Legend 2 was announced
Smith made headlines for slapping Chris
Rock at the Oscars putting the fate of
several of his future projects in
Jeopardy since the release would likely
come several years after the incident
it's possible that I am Legend 2 will
still go ahead with Smith attached
despite the better part of four decades
having passed since the Last Starfighter
first wowed audiences the time may
actually be ideal for a sequel the film
was about a teenager who beats a video
game only to discover that the game was
really a recruiting tool in order to
find soldiers to fight in an
Interstellar Alien War video games have
changed a lot since then which could
present a natural way to continue the
story speaking to movie hole Jonathan
betual the writer of the original film
set at the sequel It's not a remake it's
going to continue the story what's
changed is time itself certainly is the
video world and the alien world have
continued to tick away it's not a time
capsule of the 80s by any means we're
taking it to the next level passing the
torch or the joystick 900
are you gonna bust the record virtual
will be co-writing the sequel titled the
last starfighters with screenwriter Gary
witta in March 2021 witta tweeted a
Sizzle reel that hints at the plot of
the film an alien attempts to
assassinate an adult Alex the
protagonist of the first film and Alex
heads off into space to get to the
bottom of what's going on according to
betzial the road to making a sequel has
been a rocky one that's taken years but
at one point he was optimistic it would
finally get off the ground Betsy will
told movie hole in 2020 Gary's A Gifted
collaborator we'll be writing the script
together but it's taken a long time I
had to go through a process that took
years to recapture the rights but that
was recently completed and although
nothing is ever clear sailing it looks
like we have a really good opportunity
now however Gary witha isn't quite as
optimistic in September 2022 a fan asked
him on Twitter if there were any updates
on the film he tweeted in response no to
be honest there's a decent chance it
never happens but if it doesn't it won't
be for the lack of effort on my and
John's part
your move creeps RoboCop is back
according to deadline the cyborg star is
returning to the big screen although it
seems this new film is going to mess
around with the continuity the original
RoboCop was directed by Paul verhoven
and it made quite a killing when it was
released in 1987. after two sequels the
franchise was rebooted in 2014 with
actor Joel Kinnaman and director Jose
Padilla the latest entry in the
franchise will be called RoboCop returns
and will feature a fresh cast though
Neil blomkamp was initially attached to
direct he announced in August 2019 that
scheduling conflicts had forced him to
depart the project in November 2019
Orion pictures announced that director
Abe Forsyth had taken up the Helm of
Robocop Returns the screenplay for
RoboCop returns was originally penned in
1998 by Ed newmeyer and Michael minor
the same writers behind the first film
and it will receive a rewrite from
foresight a forsyth's version of the
script new fire had nothing but good
things to say telling sci-fi wire
I didn't want to say too much about what
the script should be I wanted him to
have the ideas and not worry about any
other version of it including ours and
just do his own thing it was very nice
to be able to say that to someone like
Abe with confidence what he came back
with was really interesting it felt
relevant and really crackled
mere days after the 2021 Chris Pratt
Sci-Fi Action film The Tomorrow War
dropped on Amazon Prime Amazon Studios
and skydance were already talking about
a sequel the first film centered around
Pratt's character who's recruited as a
soldier to travel to the Future and
fight a war to save Humanity the sequel
would reportedly bring back the entire
main cast along with director Chris
McKay and writer Zach Dean
identify yourself I'm I'm Dan Forester
the tomorrow War earned an enthusiastic
reaction from Amazon Prime subscribers
who viewed it enough for it to debut as
the number one film across streaming
platforms over the July 4th holiday
weekend so it's no wonder that the
studios would be eagerly circling a
sequel although no plans are confirmed
yet and while we don't yet know what the
story of a potential the Tamara War 2
would be we have no doubt it will be
just as thrilling and action-packed as
the first film
Tron released by Disney in 1982
represented a milestone it was the first
film featuring long sequences rendered
entirely with computers Jeff Bridges
played video game designer Kevin Flynn
who gets trapped in one of his own
projects and teams up with a software
program as they Traverse a laser-lit
digital world the film earned a modest
33 million dollars and became a cult
classic so much so that Disney released
Tron legacy in 2010 starring Garrett
Hedlund is Flynn's son who enters the
dangerous cyber Dimension to retrieve
his father Tron legacy performed well
enough to prompt Disney to order a
sequel Tron Ascension Tron legacy
director Joseph Kosinski had the entire
film written and storyboarded when
Disney canceled the project in 2015.
according to vulture that third Tron
movie Project laid dormant for seven
years according to the Hollywood
Reporter Academy Award winner Jared Leto
stepped up to try to get Tron 3 into
production as far back as 20 17 and
director Garth Davis signed on in 2020.
finally in 2023 Disney agreed and green
lit a new Tron movie titled Tron Ares a
direct sequel to Tron legacy the new
film will starletto yoshim roning a
live-action Disney favorite is set to
direct
[Music]